there's nothing supernatural or
explicitly horrifying about akunohana
translated as flowers of evil
but instead a better word to describe it
in my eyes is disturbing
it's a story about hidden desires and
acting on impulse and it provides an
exploration into the easily manipulative
nature of a defiled youth
and at the end of the day it made me
feel the way that i believed they wanted
to through the incredibly realistic
animation and slow burning narrative
very very uneasy before i begin talking
about flowers of evil if you enjoy manga
or anime in general subscribing would be
huge
over ninety percent of my viewers own
sub yet and the support would mean a lot
enjoy the video it starts off as a story
about a harmless middle schooler named
takao with a crush
he's a huge bookworm he's different from
other people nanako's is muse an object
of perfection in his eyes
and everything's normal and that's
something that the show means to
emphasize throughout its entirety
that everything occurring throughout is
real that it could happen to anyone and
that unnerving immersion
is part of the fear of it all takao
stumbles upon nanaku's gym bag
you know the kind the one that's
carrying her sweaty gross clothes from
volleyball
and accidentally takes it back home as
he runs away from school
he's seen by a girl named nakamura the
creepy class outcast and the story takes
off from here
she forces him into a contract that he
must do anything she says as long as she
tells no one about him stealing her
clothes
which devolves into a dark game of
manipulation
as i said earlier the show goes into
depth about hidden impulses and
understanding your true desires and so
throughout your left thinking
was it an accident when he took them
takao constantly defends himself to
nakamura claiming himself not to be the
pervert that she calls them
but questions are always being raised
why couldn't he just leave them
should he even have been opening that
bag glorifying them in the first place
if he weren't a pervert
the innocent boy is contrasted by the
weird and manipulative girl
but as the story continues and he's
defiled further you're forced to
question how innocent he truly is and as
we see these two characters interact
more and seclude themselves from the
rest of the world which is seen as
normal
we see how frightening the impulse of
youth can become
takao is forced into situations where he
must wear her gym clothes under his
clothes as he goes on a date with nanako
and once he and nakamura defile the
classroom that's meant to represent
normality you're kept on
edge throughout what makes it even
scarier is the way the art style was
adapted completely differently from the
manga which i honestly believe was a
good decision
after reading a manga after completing
the show there was a certain aspect i
felt was lacking
and it was certainly the realism of the
anime it's almost 3d and the way
characters are animated is directly
based off of real life like movements
the barrier between you what real life
is in the anime
is removed and you're perpetually left
in a state where it's horrifying to
watch
yet you can't take your eyes off of it
not to mention the amount of music used
is extremely minimal
until you get to the incredibly
unnerving ending song of the show that
plays in the last scenes of each episode
it isn't kept to a credits or closing a
scene like a normal anime
but similar to a season finale is
overlaid over the final scenes to create
a cliffhanger effect in
almost every episode it's hauntingly
addicting and i don't want to give a lot
of spoilers because it's certainly an
experience that everyone should have on
their own
but after what is essentially the climax
of the 13 episode anime
there's a nine-minute walking sequence
which yeah might be overkill but
it's just so immersive just as takao has
reached his limits and expressed his
true desires or at least what he thinks
is true
gone past the point of no return we have
to sit with him as he silently reflects
on what he's done
for nine whole minutes what if that were
me what would i do here what would
happen to him
the nine minutes of no music no talking
just the atmospheric sounds of a town in
the early morning that he feels
estranged in
it's beautiful yet has a frightening
effect on your mind as it builds
suspense towards the ending act of the
show
it's a criticism on the expectations of
youth and what they should
always be doing how they should act it
makes you question whether you would
even go that far
whether it was worth it what he did and
what's so scary
is that self-reflection that both takao
and yourself do
i recommend you watch it i don't think
the show is a masterpiece per se
but i think it easily surpasses the goal
it aim to achieve by shaking its
audience to its core
in an utterly addicting frightening and
real story
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
[Music]